Randall Kennedy and great pleasure of
meeting you here at Harvard behalf of
law school and you're one of the
professor's here once upon a time
Michelle Obama was a research assistant
of you Barack Obama was one of the
students here at a half at Law School
and St half of law school the
intellectual epicenter of American
democracy the intellectual epicenter of
American democracy no I wouldn't say
it's the epicenter of American democracy
it's certainly an important place it's
one of the places that produces
influential leaders in various aspects
of American life in terms of business in
terms of law in terms of politics so
it's certainly an important institution
and influential institution I wouldn't
call it the epicenter however what are
we send us off American democracy ah one
of the things about American democracy
in america united states of america is
huge 300 million people covers a
continent um they're a variety of
centers which for good and for bad I
mean power really is dispersed in
various ways because it's dispersed it
can also lead to gridlock why do you
consider the United States of America
which is conceived in the world as the
biggest the most powerful democracy a
dysfunctional democracy well I mean so
here you have this incredibly rich
country yet there are millions and
millions of Americans live lives of
deprivation including millions and
millions of children no no no fault of
their own you with adults you might say
well they were imprudent they were
profligate they were you know they they
they allow themselves to become addicted
to this or that
well but what about children children
don't have any control over who you know
who brings them into the world we had
millions of children in the United
States who grow up in circumstances in
which do they have an equal opportunity
and equal chance the answer is no yet in
this remarkably rich country we do we
allow that well for me one of the things
that I write about of course is race
relations in the United States in the
United States of America we still live
in a pigment Aqua sea in which the
darker you are in the United States the
more you are at risk of various of
suffering various social catastrophes
premature death eviction incarceration
all of the bad things if you are doctor
if you were dark you are more at risk of
those things happening to you even in
the age of Barack Obama that's right a
black American is in the White House we
have a black American who's Attorney
General of the United States so we have
some black people done very well and
there has been changed in the United
States over the past 50 years and
certainly is there's been remarkable
change still we live in a pigment Agra
see that is one way in which yes we have
a in the United States of America the
deeply dysfunctional democracy